we imagine the Chamberlain hike these is
our top line we're skipping Valley Tom
hi milk will you be my day he'll know
why I need a BZ to take me out to eat by
me easy and watch the ski stands off my
draw that's what I got mom ah
hey Grover will you go to dinner with me
- now I've seen Kalinin your thirst
palette LeBron's gonna boo boo all over
Minnesota tonight and I can't miss the
goat ah hey Jamal will you be my
Valentine
oh sorry boo but my mother just found
out she got the HIV so uh yeah me and my
dad we gotta go off hunt down magic in
the seek revenge
Oh is you ready for our date tonight
sorry boo you got to get in line to get
with this nine ah hi cutie you want to
tighten me out tonight damn boo what'd
you eat for lunch
you got some certified playgroup for
halitosis
what's up Jamal you want to be my
Valentine if Nick
[Music]